right boys it's back to school time with
a quiz let me review first detention
detention how do you spell napomniacci
English style look how he's struggling
he's struggling right now I cannot write
properly so can I I spell it out instead
okay spelling me you can start first so
it's n e p o m and i c h t c h y isn't
there no a after I and nipple right yeah
yeah and then from me yeah but I love to
say but you didn't say okay I just said
it wrong just because I cannot speak it
doesn't mean that I'm wrong first he was
telling us not to trust his writing then
it's not to trust his talking I just now
you have to do like in the spelling bee
from
n-e-p-o-m-n-i-a-c-h-t-c-h-iashi yes